[Music]
welcome to the program we start in
afghanistan where fighting is escalating
between the taliban and a resistance
group in the panshir valley the
mountainous enclave is about 150
kilometers north of the capital kabul
it's been the only province to hold out
against the taliban despite being
entirely surrounded the national
resistance front is a multi-ethnic group
made up of militias and former afghan
security force members dozens of people
have been killed on both sides in recent
days charles stratford has more from a
village close to the valley
behind me you'll just about be able to
see the town of gulbahar now that is the
entrance to the panchayat valley the
only entrance to the panchaya valley
civilian population in the thousands
when we arrived there was a lot of smoke
there was a lot of artillery being fired
at that town we understand that the
taliban the taliban are in control of it
but
they have been responding as well in the
last five minutes or so again more
artillery heavy machine gun fire
being heard we've spoken to locals in
the area many locals telling us how
terrified they are
they say the fighting started about four
days ago and as i say they they say that
it's especially bad at night it has been
escalating they also say that um the
resistance this group called the nrf
that are in control of panchayat valley
they said that they saw this group
pulling in weapons bringing in weapons
into the area in and around the time
that the taliban took control or pushing
towards taking control of kabul
preparing themselves for this fight now
bear in mind that this valley is
historically known for its for its
strong resistance the soviets were never
able to take it the taliban have never
been able to take it it is
95
plus tajik population of around 100 150
000
the resistance is being led by a man
called ahmed massoud the son of a very
famous fighter against the russians in
the 80s um we know that there have been
negotiations in the last few days
obviously they have fallen by the
wayside now they have failed
afghanistan's future was one of the
topics discussed during a meeting
between the british and pakistani
foreign ministers dominic rabb says the
uk is boosting aid for afghanistan's
neighbours as they deal with refugees
fleeing the country and his pakistani
counterpart shah mahmud gureshi says
that he'll stand with any afghan
government that's backed by the people
there are certain compulsions that we
have to deal with that perhaps you don't
have to for example
there are daily crossings of about 20 to
25 000 people in normal times
that's a huge number
can we block them
no we can't
can we regulate them yes we should uh
are there risks yes they are there are
organizations over there that are not
friendly to you us and or anyone so we
have regard against that as well
bulk of their trade
goes through pakistan
do we keep our borders open
can we close them and if we do close
them
are we contributing to a humanitarian
crisis over there
right
and
if we have to trade with them
then who do we talk to
anyone who's in charge
engaging with that authority is a
compulsion uh that we have to deal with
so
recognizing
these
challenges
pakistan said
it's for afghans
to decide about their future
we will engage with a a a
a government
that has the backing of the people of
afghanistan
well osama bin laden is in bashar and
pakistan has more on the foreign
minister's meeting
there is a lot of emphasis on pakistan's
facilitation
that's something that was discussed
between dominic raab and uh foreign
minister shaman with qureshi they also
discussed about how the uk can help
pakistan to cope with this crisis as you
heard the the foreign minister making
the case for pakistan we've we've been
speaking to him in the last few weeks
and he told me as well that pakistan has
been hosting a number of refugees
millions of them rather in pakistan
without recognition from the
international community dominic raab
today assuring him that there is going
to be somewhere around 40 million
dollars of additional funding for
afghanistan neighbors to help facilitate
the afghans and others coming to these
countries there were also a lot of other
issues that were discussed in this
meeting
pakistan and the united kingdom's
bilateral relations this the issue of a
foreign
action task force about the finances for
terrorist funding
and all of those issues coming down
towards pakistan's role that it is
playing in trying to facilitate some
sort of a peaceful transition in
afghanistan
a taliban spokesman says china has
promised to keep its embassy in
afghanistan open and to increase aid the
chinese government says it wants to play
a role in the reconstruction of the
country but it hasn't given many details
katrina you has more from beijing
well china's foreign ministry has posted
a statement on its website confirming
that the phone call took place
in that statement it was quite brief it
affirmed the friendship between the two
countries and it wished the people of
afghanistan well in going forward and
rebuilding their country but it was
quite scant on details this
message by the taliban could be its way
of putting a little bit of pressure on
beijing perhaps to keep its promises
beijing has said that it will play a
role in the economic reconstruction of
the country but it's been quite vague as
to how it intends to do that but no
doubt that beijing doesn't tend to play
a role here because it does have some
existing investments in afghanistan that
it probably wants to protect it also has
very extensive investments in
neighboring pakistan so it is looking at
the economic potential of the country
and the impact on the region at large
now china as a major player was one of
the first to recognize the taliban as a
legitimate political force we had
taliban leader abdulgani bharadha
actually visit china in late july and he
met with china's foreign minister wang
yi and throughout this whole process
throughout the takeover as well as this
transition china's embassy in kabul has
remained fully open and operational now
beijing has been very critical of the us
saying that its hasty withdrawal was to
blame for the chaos caused in the
country but at the same time china has
said that the u.s should not just cut
and run that it has responsibilities in
the country and should help contribute
to its economic rebuilding as well
andrew small is a senior transatlantic
fellow with the german marshall fund of
the united states asia program he says
china stands to gain a lot by working
with a new afghan administration
suddenly over the long term if china was
able to get some of the mines that it's
already committed to particularly the
inact copper mine but some of the
lithium investments and other things
there are significant resources there
china's one of the actors that is is
keen to step in and benefit from it and
the level of
revenue that could accrue to the taliban
to a future afghan government would be
very significant but that's many years
away in fact before that really
translates into
meaningful resources for whoever is in
power so you have a short-term question
which is in the immediate economic
crisis
and the immediate aftermath of a new
government what is what sort of um
measures is china willing to take in
those circumstances china doesn't do
large-scale aid it will provide aid uh
in more modest terms it provides
humanitarian assistance and it's not
going to bail out a new government and
it may do some smaller scale investments
but those longer term investments even
will depend on there being enough
stability in the country enough security
in the country for these to turn into
something that's economically viable
china also wants to make sure that it's
a government that's sufficiently
politically stable that they can make
these long-term bets so there are still
some limitations to what china's really
going to be willing to do economically
even if it's continues to be happy and
the taliban are keen to be able to send
these signals that china's